im studio begrüße ich die sicherheits
und verteidigungsexperten claudia major
herzlich willkommen von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik guten morgen
sagen sie wie bewerten sie denn die
verschiebung dieses referendums aus
vermeintlichen sicherheitsgründen sowie
die russische seite es propagiert das
ist zum einen eine gute nachricht denn
der verweis auf sicherheitsgründe heißt
das anscheinend die ukrainische
offensive russland wirklich zu schaffen
macht also es ist erstmal ein positives
signal aber man sollte sich da auch
nicht täuschen denn das referendum wurde
nicht abgesagt das ist erstmal noch
verschoben das heißt russland hält an
der idee immer noch fest diese gebiete
zu annektieren und ein russisches
territorium zu verwandeln und hinzu
kommt russland kann auch ohne ein
referendum die sogenannte and ukraine
sierung split fortsetzen das heißt auch
ohne ein referendum kann die bevölkerung
dort unterdrückt werden das heißt das
klingt erstmal nach einer positiven
neuigkeit aber faktisch ändert sich
erstmal nicht viel für die besetzten
gebiete die weiterhin von russland
gesetzt und unterdrückt werden können
die ukrainischen streitkräfte dann
wirklich gerade größere teile
zurückerobern ich glaube das ist ein
kleines missverständnis und blick auf
die offensive wenn wir an off von
offensive reden denken wir oft über
große land gewinner und die ukrainische
streitkräfte die politiker sagen auch
immer wieder das ziel dieser offensive
ist erstmal die russischen
versorgungslinien die die knotenpunkte
und sagen hinter den linien russland zu
schwächen um dann möglicherweise auch
geländegewinne zu machen und damit
machen sie ziemliche fortschritte also
in dem versorgungslinien in dem
kommandoposten und ähnliches zerstört
werden und russland damit geschwächt
wird wie wichtig ist denn da jetzt
gerade auch die militärische hilfe aus
dem westen inwieweit hilft das den
ukrainischen streitkräfte nach
vorzurücken man sagt vereinfacht
formuliert dass der einen krieg oder
einen militärischen konflikt für sich
entscheiden kann der die lücken bei
personal also bei den soldaten aber auch
beim material der kassen ausrüstung
wieder schließen kann und dafür braucht
die ukraine die westliche unterstützung
das heißt die ausrüstung mit modernen
waffen mit schweren waffen mit
artillerie und ähnlichen sind für die
ukraine überlebensnotwendig weil sie
sonst kein territorium zurückerobern
können es geht ja nicht darum russland
abzuwehren sondern es geht darum
besetztes gebiet wirklich
zurückzuerobern jetzt gab es ja immer
wieder vereinzelt angriffe auf russische
stellen auch in der grimm inwieweit
schwächen denn die ukraine statt hatten
die russischen besatzer zahlungskräftig
in der region tatsächlich oder wird
etwas verlängert also diese diese
schläge auch hinter die linien also ins
hinterland sind enorm wichtig weil sie
einmal russischen depots oder auch
logistikketten zerstören das heißt wir
müssen sie wieder aufbauen das bindet
kräfte weil dann muss müssen die
russischen truppen ihre eigenen
beispielsweise lagerstätten besser
beschützen es hat aber auch im
psychologischen effekt auf die
russischen soldaten was natürlich
verunsichert aber auch auf die
öffentlichkeit wir haben das auf den
anschlägen nach den anschlägen auf die
krim gesehen wo auch die russischen
urlauber auf einmal geflohen sind das
heißt es schwächt russland hinter den
linien s demoralisiert aber auch die
truppen und damit ist es ein wichtiges
element in dieser aktuellen offensive
jetzt beschäftigt uns gerade in den
letzten tagen auch die situation rund um
das akw in the bridge wie groß ist das
risiko das von sabratha auch geradeaus
geht also das risiko ist groß weil es
immer noch in dieser sehr prekären lage
ist das ukrainische personal das
atomkraftwerk am laufen hält aber
russische soldaten auf dem gelände sind
und das immer wieder bedrohen und damit
gibt es natürlich das risiko einer eines
unfalls oder auch einer fehlenden
stromversorgung für das atomkraft sagt
selbst es gibt jetzt zwei experten
anscheinend der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde die vor ort sind und
dokumentieren können aber das löst ja zu
sagen die herausforderung für das
atomkraftwerk nicht und auch nicht für
die stromversorgung für die ukraine das
des atomkraft gerade den süden der
ukraine versorgt hat also es bleibt mit
blick auf sicherheit schwierig und
energieversorgung dennoch bleibt die
lage dort sehr unübersichtlich gerade
serbe schiesst du eigentlich wer mit
welchem ziel kann man das sagen genau
also momentan ist es auch das so dass
auf dem gelände russische streitkräfte
sind das heißt momentan ist die präsenz
dort stärker aber es ist unheimlich
schwer nachzuvollziehen wer eigentlich
genau was macht aber im endeffekt geht
es darum wird dieses werk geschützt kann
man unfällen oder anderen risiken
vorbeugen oder nicht und da hilft auch
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
die jetzt dabei den letzten tagen einer
untersuchung schauen wir perspektivisch
noch mal wie wird es jetzt weitergehen
mit dem krieg auch im blick gerade auf
den winter
also der winter ist tatsächlich eine
riesenherausforderung das ist eine
herausforderung für die ukraine weil sie
natürlich das land am laufen halten muss
wir haben gesehen dass russland die
zivile infrastruktur das heißt
wohnhäuser stromwerke systematisch
zerstört hat es gibt seit kriegsbeginn
über 11 millionen flüchtlinge es gibt
oder die häuser verlassen haben es gibt
selbst sechs millionen intern innen
flüchtlinge das heißt die ukraine muss
diese leute versorgen mit heizung mit
ernährung und dass es eine enorme
herausforderung zumal auch das
wirtschaftswachstum in der ukraine
natürlich eingebrochen ist weil
einnahmen beispielsweise aus getreide
oder stahlexporte weggefallen sind das
heißt die interne situation das land am
laufen zu halten ist eine
herausforderung zweitens ist die
herausforderung die unterstützung im
westen aufrecht zu erhalten die ukraine
braucht die finanzielle unterstützung
der westlichen staaten aber auch die
militärische unterstützung und die
länger ist läuft das du mehr sinkt die
aufmerksamkeit also wir sind auch
gefragt und drittens ist die
herausforderung mit blick auf russland
das wo die sorge besteht dass sich die
russen truppen russischen truppen
eingraben konsolidieren und eigentlich
immer stärker im ukrainischen
territorium festkrallen das heißt da
sind mindestens drei herausforderungen
die den winter sehr schwierig machen
werden wir werden das weiter verfolgen
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung
claudia jung von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik
kennen